what about the combat system that does
seem to be an important part of a lot of
games you started in the beginning yeah
every time yep
so usually we're making that first
playable it's an area you can go through
some amount of dialogue so I'm out of
combat
how do you get the combat right what's
the secret to a great combat system
well first on a control side helping the
player when they don't realize it
there's a lot of tricks you can do with
magnetism in terms of the controller and
where the attacks go so it has to feel
the minute to minute has to feel really
good in your hands there's a lot of
Animation time
right and changing animations so they're
impactful and they they happen at a rate
that the player feels
like they're really doing it and then
ultimately it's the illusion that the
enemies are smart
but they really
are there for you to kill them right so
they do a lot of things to just let
themselves get killed they're not a near
Smart near smart as we can make them
because it turns out that is not fun
right so there's a balance between but
there's a that is I guess a kind of AI
and
it's a very intimate interaction with an
AI because it's like there's a lot of
stuff going on it's not just
very kind of shallow like a dialogue or
something like that it's like there's a
Time critical nature of it a lot of
stuff is happening and if ever if
anything feels off it's it's gonna feel
wrong yep all the games Do It
um you know it's not unique to what we
do in terms of how they handle combat
scenarios and there's some games that
just do it extremely well in terms of
um even in multiplayer where you're
playing Bots and most people don't know
it
um or how
a multiple enemy scenario is really you
know they don't all shoot you they trade
off they're gonna wait I was like I'll
just wait my turn because we don't want
to overwhelm them but he feels like you
feel like you're overwhelmed when
there's six enemies but
you know a good game will no they're
gonna they're gonna take their time
is there a science to it is it is it art
is it like
that yes I mean it's it's all of that so
it's like an iterative process where you
try different things there's a lot of
there's a lot of Animation there's a lot
of timing animation work
hard work also how does the reticule
change
um what are the little sound effects
what about like the the gamify like that
is fun
again that goes back to the winning
you know the winning is fun yes death
does not yes Let The Wookie win
I like how you have to dumb down the AI
to make it fun for humans
um because if if you didn't it would
just be just Slaughter non-stop for for
All Humans that's good to know what
about things like
um
he said cooking like crafting making
potions and poisons and uh smithing
weapons and armor cooking how do you get
that right what's what's interesting
there such an interesting like
um just you know a lot of games don't
have that kind of thing so what role
does that play you know I think we
really cracked it in a way I like with
Fallout 4 actually where when we're
doing Elder Scrolls we have like the
flowers and things and you have Alchemy
and we took this to okay if it's
post-apocalyptic what if everything in
the world
was an alchemical ingredient sometimes
so breaking it down to their components
so when you walk around a world like
that again we like the simulation we
like we like the forks and spoons and
the cups and all that okay how can I use
those to create so I love how it works
starts working in Fallout 4 where okay
all these things I find there is they
have some value
in creating or crafting outside of a cup
is worth one gold piece or one cap